and they don't want to cross that bridge
until they have to have crossed the
bridge
that i wouldn't have expected that
they'd cross
the no fun league single digit jerseys
now available for running backs
receivers tight ends defensive backs and
linebackers
that is going to be extremely
interesting as it relates to the land
rush for the single digit numbers
it is oh my god i learned a week ago
today with robert woods on the program
he wore number two in college he wants
to wear number two now with the rams
jayla ramsey wants number two with the
rams
yeah maybe they're gonna do rock paper
scissors to figure it out talk more
about rock paper scissors later but you
got to do something to figure out
who's going to get those jerseys and the
other wrinkle chris
i was reminded of this by the league
recently now i asked the question it's
not like they reached out and
and told me but it's an issue from years
ago if if you want to change your number
for the upcoming year
and there's an inventory of unsold
jerseys with your current number on them
you got to buy those
that is such a there was adrian peterson
was going to change his number and he
got the bill for what it was going to
cost to change the number he said now
wait
so uh that that could keep some of these
guys the more popular guys
yeah who are more likely to have a
stockpile of jerseys in their current
numbers it's going to be harder for them
because they're going to be the ones
more likely to have to write the check
yeah but but yeah like th i mean
okay for lack of a better way to say
that pisses me off
i mean are they so so when a guy has a
jersey
that stockpiled you know back in you
know and they got lots of
and then the team trades them or cuts
them is the nfl gonna pay that player
and go
you know well hey you know here's the
other money that you know from the
jerseys of your like
that's bs that's bs you change the rules
the rules are changed
you're going to make players pay to
change their numbers here
if there's still a lot of them back in
stockpile that i don't like
everything else i'm all for i think it
is going to be really cool
i think at first i misunderstood that i
thought there was going to be defense
and offense alignment
or defensive linemen were going to be
able to wear the single digits but i
think this is the right way the way
they're doing it
and it's going to be all out war in the
locker room for these numbers
it really is because so many of these
players yes have been single digits high
school college
they think it looks cooler i always
thought it looked cooler single digits
and you're going to have true like you
know fights in the locker room here and
like
competition and who knows what to try to
get some of these numbers
pete makes a great point too defensive
lineman defensive ends are going to want
to be
classified as linebackers right so they
can wear single digits
you need to think that through though
yeah because if you ever get franchise
tagged you'd rather be a defensive end
of the linebacker because defensive end
pays better under the franchise tag and
we
saw that issue with shaq barrett and the
buccaneers they settled that earlier
this year
before they applied the franchise tag
too yeah could have applied it to one of
the reasons they didn't apply it to him
a second time
he settled that grievance favorably and
the franchise tag for barrett would have
been over 20 million dollars the second
time around so that's another wrinkle
and chris
yes we went through this with jj walk
going to arizona and i've got on my list
of things to do
research all the retired single-digit
numbers throughout the league
because could it be that in some of
these cities
retired isn't really retired because all
of a sudden
there's a star player here we go wants
to wear that jersey number
that previously he couldn't have worn by
rule
now he can wear it and now the family
of the late insert name of guy who the
jersey was retired for
says we give our blessing because what
else are they going to say because they
it puts them in a horrible spot yeah i
don't wanna start down that rabbit hole
again but it puts the family in a
horrible spot because what are they
gonna say
no of course they're gonna say yes yeah
no but you know mike you brought up the
the out
we sat we had rashad weaver yesterday
right from pit the defense end
he said exactly what you said that he
wouldn't mind if they made him an
outside linebacker so he could wear that
number
and do that so you're right there's
going to be some tinkering there and
maybe some guys that are those kind of
hybrid outside linebackers defensive
ends who are going to go
no can you please list me as that and
maybe not understand the consequences of
that franchise tag and things like that
too
that'll be interesting to watch to see
you know what guys kind of put
themselves out there to try to do that
and weaver by the way wore 17 at pitt he
wouldn't be allowed to wear that number
no
right as a linebacker it would have to
be one or seven or eight the combination
of one plus seven one of the few math
problems that i can still solve
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports